wow tu as l'air incroyable et peut-être un peu
mal à l'aise j'ai l'air de Jane Austen
m'a vomi dessus tu ne ressemblais pas
à Jane Austen là non tu as l'
air absolument magnifique
tu peux respirer ce truc juste
il n'y a rien que j'aime plus que d'en
mettre  des vêtements amples et amples, vous savez
juste pouvoir vous détendre, vous savez, c'est
une tenue de fin de journée de travail que vous portez, vous
savez, je suis très content de me souvenir des six
articles dont j'ai besoin d'une manière ou d'une autre pour tenir mon
pantalon oh ouais
j'aime ton agitation par  la façon dont oh ouais
j'aime vraiment que la
déclaration de mode la plus séduisante qu'une femme puisse faire
aujourd'hui c'est un gros cul simulatif qui est une
simulation d'un gros cul juste là si
j'étais un gars noir c'est le tour le plus méchant que
vous pourriez me jouer parce que  Je
parce que je serais comme oh mon Dieu regarde il y a un gros
cul mon préféré et puis je le soulève
et je serais comme ah c'est une grosse blague ouais
exactement ce regard quand tu le soulèves il
n'y a rien d'autre qu'une cage en métal en dessous
là Wow tu es prêt à soulager le
stress du jour